today we will talk about algorithm
regulatory motifs in DNA and we will
start from a game when we will be
implanting patterns in random strings
let's generate ten random sequences and
then let's take a 15 nucleotide long
pattern and insert it at random
positions in these ten sequences now
johnnyo had I will hide these patterns
and tell me where this pattern sir what
Algar is should you run to figure out
where I have inserted these patterns and
you already probably recognize that if
we slightly modified our frequent words
problem we will find the pattern I have
inserted Indian you can concatenate all
these sequences and find the most
frequent world in the resulting
concatenate the implanted pattern will
appear ten times in this concatenate it
is surprisingly frequent which most
likely will mean that this was the
pattern that I have inserted now let me
change the experiment slightly now
instead of the patterns that I plant
without any changes I will insert the
same 15 nucleotide long pattern with
these four random mutations add for all
these 400 mutations at random positions
and in this case this pattern forms
so-called KD motives which is a k-mer
that appear in every sequence which is
at most D mutations can you find such a
pattern if I hide from you where
inserted it do you think that frequent
words problem will be able to help us
well that's all may be entertaining but
what biologists sank about this game I
send biologists are falling asleep
because it's absolutely unclear what
this problem has to
do movies real biological problems and I
will try to show you that this problem
is actually about a biological problem
of finding regulatory elements in DNA
my next question will be do we have a
clock think about our daily scheduler
and think how our life depends on day
and night in every cell we probably have
to express different patterns depending
on what time of the day is it but who
are these molecular timekeepers who tell
the cells in our body what is the time
right now how do this molecular
timekeeper are able to change in
expression to produce proteins needed at
night as opposed to proteins needed in
the morning and in other questions that
is relevant to this can we find genes
responsible for sleep disorder when our
circadian clock is has problems now we
will focus on plants rather than human
because for plants keeping time is a
matter of life in the end deaths
just think about photosynthesis
flowering or frost resistance if you
don't know what is the time you will be
damned if you I planned and the question
arises the how probably a thousand
plants genes in plants it should follow
the circadian clock who controls them
who are the molecular managers who tells
these genes increase gene repression or
decrease gene expression here comes a
surprise just three genes in plants are
molecular managers that are responsible
for orchestrating this circadian
behavior and their cause is a one lcy
and talked one these genes are
regulatory protein also known as
transcription factors and these genes to
control messaging to exert control over
Acadian clog they bind to short regions
maybe ten nucleotide 15 nucleotides in
the upstream regions of the genes for
example if one of these regulatory
proteins want to control particular
circadian genes it probably have
original vision thousand nucleotides
from the start of the gel weight bytes
for example he is CCA one one of these
three regulators and to exert control
over the genes it has to bind in the
upstream region of these genes but how
does CCA one know where to bind probably
there are some hidden messages that tell
CCA one bind here our goal today is to
find this particular hidden message that
shown on the slide where CCA one binds
to so two but of course we don't know
where these hidden messages I actually
hiding in the upstream regions and today
we will learn about algorithm that a our
aim at finding such hidden messages we
will start from formulating the problem
so when we talked about implanting a
15-mile with these four and remote
ations we figure out that frequent words
algorithm would not work to find it
because there are no frequent words that
appear in without mutations in the
resulting strings after implantations
that's why we need to solve a different
problem that I call the implanted
massive problems in this problem you are
given a set of strengths DNA and an
introduced K and D and you need to find
all KD motives in DNA now how should we
solve this problem should we possibly
explore all possible 4 to the power K
k-mers and see which of them represent
KD motives that will take time that's
why let's try something else let's try
to see whether pairwise comparison can
airing sequences to each other would
help think about this each sequence is
random the only non randomness in the
sequence is this implanted motifs and
that's why they probably exhibit larger
similarity than other regions of random
sequences there's my idea let's find the
most close 15 mares let's say in the
first and second sequence and it will
give us an idea on how the implanted
pattern looks like would it work let's
figure out whether the pairwise
comparison between strengths will help
us to find the implanted motifs well
unfortunately it won't work
because when the implant pattern it has
four differences from the original
pattern but there have they don't have
access to the pattern so there is
nothing to compare this the only things
that we have are implanted instances but
every two implanted instance is actually
four plus four would maybe make four
plus four mutations apart how can define
them since pairwise comparison won't
work maybe the only option we have is
just to explore all four to the power K
possible k-mers should we explore all of
them not necessarily because if a k-mer
is so far away from all k-mers in the
strings that we analyzed there is no
reason to explore it it cannot possibly
be an implanted pattern that's why my
teeth enumeration algorithm exists we
will start from each cameo from a
sequence let's call it a for each side
k-mers let's generate all possible
mutations which is up to D nucleotides
mutated and for each such mutated Kaymer
a prime let's check whether it appears
as a KD Mir in the strength that will
work but the question is it will be slow
but definitely will work if K is small
but the question of you should
would it solve the real biological
problem unfortunately it won't it won't
work because our model for implanting
patterns is not very biological it
doesn't properly reflect biological
reality I would say little bit messy
biological reality because when
biologists generate let's say a set of
genes that are controlled by circadian
clock they cannot guarantee that all
these genes have a particular pattern
implanted some genes don't have any
patterns implanted in the upstream
regions as a result we need to find out
a way to search for motives even if some
sequences don't have any motives
implanted and that makes our life little
bit more difficult and we need to
develop scoring for every set of my tips
even in the case when some of the
implanted patterns do not look very
similar to the canonical motif and we'll
move to the next topic which is my key
finding problem that is more adequately
reflect finding regulatory motifs